there are some people who would get
tired of being placed in charge of
scp-914 or the clockworks the monotony
of it all might make most of us go mad
the same routine day after day placing
an infinite number of objects into the
intake booth of the machine selecting
one of the modes be it rough coarse
one-to-one fine or very fine and seeing
just what sort of transformation takes
place but there was one employee of the
scp foundation who liked that routine
just fine dr gears was happy with his
position the simplicity of the routine
the predictability of it all he liked
when the days stacked neatly together in
a row of uneventful stretches of time it
was why he ate the exact same meal for
lunch every day a plain turkey sandwich
on white bread a cup of water and a
single banana of course there was some
variety in the events that came about
when testing the clockworks there was
that incident with dr curtis and the
pound of bacon placed inside the machine
alongside a photograph of scp-682
it had resulted in a miniature replica
of
scp-682 made entirely out of bacon
capable of movement and extremely
hostile though its size prevented it
from doing any damage it did still
attempt to kill any staff it could find
it had smelled mouth watering but dr
gears had suspended dr curtis from
testing with
scp-914 for the trouble and a day of
having bacon grease cleaned off of every
surface in the vicinity there was also
the incident that occurred when dr hertz
in an attempt to score some free music
production placed a cd of his own
original guitar songs into the machine
on the setting very fine rather than
improving the production quality of the
tracks on the cd the machine produced a
completely silent cd as well as a
collection of books on songwriting
singing and playing the guitar for
beginners dr gears had to physically
drag dr hertz from the room when upset
by the blow to his ego he attempted to
attack the machine
and of course there had been the highly
destructive super bouncy ball incident
which resulted in 45 casualties and
staggering damage to the facility as
well as the aforementioned ball which
was currently thought to be somewhere in
space most likely orbiting mars but for
the most part it was always the same
thing an object went in a setting was
selected and the object came out in a
new modified state wash rinse repeat
just like it said on the back of the
bottle of the brand of unscented shampoo
dr gears had been using for the past 30
years that was how he liked it and as he
sat at his desk going over the test logs
and preparing to supervise another round
of tests he turned on some of his
favorite tunes well i say tunes but it
was really a white noise machine he
didn't care for music it was a bit too
much excitement he was just getting into
the flow of his work when there was a
knock at his office door
excuse me sir a research assistant was
standing at the door pale and anxious a
clipboard in his hands they're um
requesting your help with an emergency
down the hall what is it dr gears asked
they didn't really say just something
about dr bright and um chainsaws the
assistant stammered dr gears sighed and
stood up from his desk i'll be right
there
there wouldn't be anyone keeping an eye
on scp-914 but at this point the
experimentation process basically ran
itself everything would be fine if dr
gear stepped away for a little while
wouldn't it meanwhile across the site a
very enterprising mask became keenly
aware of an opportunity presenting
itself it had been lying in weight
meticulously planning and plotting for
days and now
there was an opening it could take
advantage of you see months ago the mask
had managed to finagle itself a host a
researcher who had just been working
with scp-914
when the mask's consciousness took over
the mans and it delved into all of his
thoughts as they were snuffed out one by
one it learned all about the marvelous
miraculous clockworks the machine
capable of transforming anything into a
better version of itself the mask had
fantasized obsessed about getting to
scp-914
of using it to mold itself to change
into something greater and more powerful
then perhaps it could escape this place
and return to its former freedom and
glory of course it would have to select
the right setting one wrong choice and
the whole plan could amount to nothing
on rough the mask would likely be
destroyed reduced to a pile of ceramic
dust or perhaps even a ball of unmolded
clay alongside some of the black slime
always oozing from its eyes and mouth on
course it would likely be transformed
into a slab of plain porcelain uncarved
and unpainted on one to one the mask
would likely be swapped out with another
anomalous object some other enterprising
mask or perhaps a haunted victorian doll
or some other malicious inanimate thing
and what use would that be no that
wouldn't do at all
fine could be promising and would likely
prevent the mask from degrading any
future hosts it decided to take but why
stop there why should it limit itself to
simply fine when very fine was right
there and looking oh so promising it
decided if it could get to scp-914
it would find a way to transform itself
using the very fine setting and then its
enemies this pathetic foundation the
entire world would fall to their knees
it had been waiting patiently like a
snake coiled and ready to snap up its
prey spreading its psychic tendrils as
far as they could go and anticipating
the moment that someone left scp-914
unattended now the moment had arrived of
course the mask would need help it
didn't have a way to reach the
clockworks on its own so it had been
wrapping its influence around the guard
station just outside its door dripping
thoughts into his head whispering
darkness into his ear at every chance it
got chipping away at his will bit by bit
until the man was little more than a
puppet with the possessive mask tugging
at his strings the mask gave a mental
yank on one of those strings calling the
man in its thrall into the room first he
knocked out his fellow guard with the
butt of his gun at this point his mind
was so pliable that he would do anything
to please the mask next the man entered
the containment chamber a glassy vacant
look in his eyes he unlocked the glass
case and reached inside lifting the mask
out and bringing it one step closer to
absolute freedom he tucked the mask
inside of his uniform hiding it away
from any prying eyes and began to walk
steadily towards as cp 914's room all
the while the mask whispered silent
encouragements into the man's weakened
mind promising him power and success
beyond his wildest dreams if only he
would help it achieve this goal of
course the mask was planning to kill the
man as soon as his task was done but he
didn't need to know that yet every step
brought the mask closer to victory and
it was practically vibrating with the
delicious anticipation of it all
soon
so soon
they reached the containment room the
clockworks just beyond the door the
guard carried the mask into the room
place the mask inside of the intake
booth closed it and approached the
control panel in accordance with the
mask's psychic instructions he selected
very fine and turned the machine on the
cogs and gears inside word to life the
engine sputtered metal clanked and pipes
exhaled hissing bursts of energy the
output chamber opened and through the
curtain of steam scp-035
stepped in its new and improved form
that's right
stepped first one long sinewy leg
leathery shiny and black as the knight
extended into view
another leg followed and along with it
came a torso a pair of arms a slender
neck and the familiar face of the mask
stark white against the darkness of its
new body the feat ended in little points
as if the figure was wearing boots but
there was no visible clothing it was all
one being angular and strange with long
long fingers tipped with curved claws
the mask let out a wicked cackle
throwing back its head in triumph
[Laughter]
excellent it's even better than i
imagined
the mask turned to the guard that had
helped it escape thank you for your
service now i have one last favor to ask
you
it was time for the mask to test its
powers to see how the clockworks had
strengthened what was already there what
more it was capable of in this enhanced
state i want you to go into the
cafeteria walk into the kitchen and
climb into the oven would you make sure
you turn it on nice and hot first it
waited for a few seconds before the man
nodded solemnly turned and left the room
heading off in the direction of the
cafeteria it listened as the moments
passed and the sound of horrified
shocked screams rang out and it knew
that the man had followed its
instructions exactly at the mask's
orders he had cooked himself for lunch
the mask clapped its hands together
cackling again
[Laughter]
wonderful oh wonderful now that's taken
care of what shall i try next if the
mask had eyebrows they would have been
arched in a truly devilish expression
first it wanted to test its abilities on
a truly formidable opponent someone
worthy of the mask's time and attention
casually as you please it strode over to
one particular containment chamber to
see about an unkillable reptile as it
walked several guards took notice
pointing their weapons at the mask and
ordering it to stand down
each time it chuckled and with the wave
of its hand the barrels of their guns
warped and twisted into little metal
bows completely useless it snapped its
clawed fingers and the guards fell to
the ground in an unconscious heap can't
have you sounding the alarm yet the fun
is only just beginning the mask remarked
though it knew the guards couldn't hear
it it kicked open the door to
scp-682's containment room with a jaunty
greeting
hello you scaly fool i come to pay you a
visit the reptile did not respond
incapacitated by its hydrochloric acid
bath that just wouldn't do the mass
concentrated and the steel chamber broke
apart acid spilling everywhere hissing
as it splashed onto any available
surface
scp-682 lifted its head twitching its
tail
and took in the sight of the new and
improved mask what do you think the mask
posed for the creature laughing again it
seemed it couldn't stop laughing lately
its expression fixed into a permanent
gleeful smile
it couldn't help it freedom and power
just felt so good
disgusting
scp-682 remarked unimpressed with this
display it lunged at the mask preparing
to attack but the mask held up a hand to
stop it not so fast
scp-682
suddenly froze in place eyes rolling
wildly as it tried desperately in vain
to move
let's see
what should i do with you
the mask was itching to test out its
reality warping abilities it had the
feeling that there was very little it
couldn't do in this state and wanted to
see just how far its power could go but
what would be suitable punishment what
could be the cruelest possible thing to
do to such a creature the mass could
simply try to kill it to finally snuff
out this endless miserable life but that
would be a release
that would be far too easy
a light bulb went off in the mask's
twisted mind perfect it waved its hand
releasing scp-682 from its paralysis but
as the massive lizard snapped its jaws
and moved to take a bite out of the mask
it lost its balance falling to the
ground its legs had begun to shrink
rapidly knocking its center of gravity
as skew
soon the rest of its body began to
follow getting smaller and smaller at an
unbelievable pace until finally where
there had once stood a massive
impossible prehistoric beast with
something resembling a baby alligator a
tiny little tail thrashing about short
stubby legs bulbous eyes and a mouth
full of sharp but adorable
non-threatening teeth when the shrunken
scp-682 spoke its voice was high-pitched
and squeaky
[Music]
it roared yes
you are the mask turned and left
thoroughly pleased with its work and
shut the door behind it now what other
fellow anomalies could the mask exercise
its absolute superiority over it
pondered other supposedly dangerous and
deadly entities that it had heard about
over its time in foundation custody it
all seems so
laughable now there was only one true
danger within these walls and it was the
mask oh
what about that abominable sculpture the
ugly thing with a penchant for snapping
necks but only when a person wasn't
looking at it the absolute coward
cowards didn't deserve to live the mask
decided and it made its way over toward
scp-173's containment cell
inside there were several d-class
staring at the statue with wide
unblinking eyes each person terrified of
being the one to let their guard down
and lose their life in the process
none of them would die today however at
least not at the hands of the statue as
the d-class in the cell watched never
once taking their eyes off of scp-173
the statue's head began to twist and
rotate the sound of cracking snow and
creaking metal reverberating through the
room the mask used its telekinetic
abilities to rend the statue's head from
its neck relishing the irony of breaking
the thing's neck just as it had done to
so many others it wasn't about justice
of course the mask had no taste for such
inseparable human things it just found
the whole image quite funny the entire
thing began to crumble apart like a sand
castle beneath an ocean wave
disintegrating until all that was left
was a pile of pebbles and dust just like
that scp-173
was no more
as for the d-class in the cell well the
mask could use some servants you all
come with me
the mask ordered flexing its iron will
and quickly capturing the weak
fear-addled minds of the d-class
personnel before it they fell in line
shuffling out the door and following the
mask with the same blank expressions as
the guard before whatever was left of
their personalities after so much time
being used and abused by the foundation
it was gone now replaced only with the
will of the mighty mask as the mass
continued its victory tour of the
foundation now with four mindless
servants in tow it passed the staff
break room through the window it spotted
one dr bright the tell-tale amulet
around his neck microwaving some
leftover pizza the mask had always found
dr bright distasteful with the
self-aggrandizing pranks and general
dedication to chaos with no grand vision
behind it no meaningful agenda it was
pitiful it was deeply ugly and now the
mask had a chance to put an end to the
immortal doctor's antics once and for
all it opened the door greeting dr
bright with that frozen grin
oh doctor
dr bright's eyes widened and he didn't
even hear the microwave behind him ding
signaling that his pizza was ready he
was too distracted by the horrifying
sight before him but as he opened his
mouth to scream to call for help the
mask reached out and ripped the amulet
from his neck the hose body fell limply
to the ground and the mask looked down
at the amulet glinting in the light that
held dr bright's consciousness inside it
stared at the amulet with a flinty gaze
and under its empty stair the metal
began to rust to degrade and to melt
into an unrecognizable slurry the mask
let it drip onto the floor then when all
that was dr bright had melted away it
wiped its hand off with a napkin and
ground the wet puddle on the ground with
its heel
goodbye doctor
the mask hissed now
what's next but as the mask turned to
walk down the hall it came face to face
with a disapproving face
scp-343 had manifested directly in front
of the mask and he clearly had learned
of the mask's behavior so far that day
you've been busy
yes very busy lots to do you see
the mask chuckled smugly you understand
why i can't allow this to continue right
343's expression remains stern but calm
you believe you can stop me the mask
tilted its head to the side of course i
can
scp-343 side but you could stop on your
own if you would rather i prefer to
avoid an unnecessary conflict the mass
giggled uncontrollably at this
[Laughter]
i am going to rend the flesh from your
bones
it's simply sad i thought you might say
something like that
i'm going to have to take your body
i'm sorry
scp-343 prepared to teleport the mask's
new body to another location separating
them and reducing the mask to its
original more manageable state but
before he could there was sudden
darkness in the room every light
blinking out all at once the hall was
plunged into shadow but this was no
ordinary darkness this darkness was inky
thick cloaking like smoke clinging to
the inside of your throat then just as
suddenly as it appeared the darkness
dissipated but
scp-343 was gone he hadn't teleported
himself to somewhere else he hadn't
walked through the wall to get away from
the mask he was truly gone the mask
couldn't be certain exactly what it had
done to scp-343
but it knew that the enemy had been
truly eradicated in fact it was fairly
certain he had been erased from reality
entirely the mask made one final lap
around the foundation containment site
bidding farewell to every anomaly it
passed some it transformed like it had
done to scp-682
taking inspiration from its bird-like
face the mask turned the plague doctor
into a crow others it simply executed
such as the poor scp-096
whose screams and shrieks had always
irritated the mask of course the
foundation began to notice what was
happening and they tried to defeat the
mask they shot at it with their puny
weapons they sounded their useless
alarms and they called for their
laughable backup but none of it mattered
not in the face of the mask guns melted
in guard's hands alarms went silent at
nothing more than a glance and more and
more mindless slaves joined the mask's
army it didn't want too many that would
just be difficult to keep track of but
an even dozen seemed like the perfect
number with this miniature army in tow
the mask finally made its way to its
final destination
the exit it had been waiting for this
moment dreaming of it since it was first
imprisoned so long ago as it stepped out
into the sun the mask realized that
though it didn't have nostrils could
smell the breeze the scent of
wildflowers and grass what a beautiful
place to mold into the mask's image of
an ideal world the world was its oyster
and the mask longed to swallow it whole
the current whereabouts of the
possessive mask are unknown the
foundation is doing its best to locate
the mask and determine new effective
measures for bringing it down and
recontaining it as soon as possible
the escape of the mask is being
considered a possible xk class end of
the world scenario if it cannot be
stopped the best and brightest minds at
the foundation are working on it aside
from dr bright of course may he rest in
peace but right now there is very little
anyone can do
so if you see a strange dark figure in a
white mask walking down the street do
yourself a favor and run the other way
before it's too late now go check out
could scp-682 be contained in the back
rooms and
scp-096 versus siren head for more
terrifying anomalous hypotheticals